today's video is sponsored by surf shark
look y'all
every [ __ ] day my baby daddy come
here
with one [ __ ] meal for my child but i
have
three other kids
we have one kid together but he only
want to come and bring one thing to
mcdonald's but what about my other kids
how come you can't feed my other kids
mcdonald's though like that focus as
hell like you're not going to sit here
and make my other kids feel left out and
you're only bringing one child something
to eat look there you go and i bet you
he only got one thing in there
i bet you he don't even
it looks like it'll fade the setup it's
like she she does the intro before he
pulls up and he pulls up and he pulls up
like a second later and you know baby
daddy's always late
just kidding oh it's just weird about
the way she did it but it was just good
i'm finna expose a lot of him so people
can see how he really is it ain't more
than it ain't more than enough food in
that bag for everybody
what's up
because i'm going to expose you
because they don't look they don't look
enough for all my kids okay what about
my other kids
my other kid's gonna be left out
you didn't feed him
you know i don't get my food steps to
the center lisa is that my problem
if you're trying to help out though
you're not helping out
i want to hear the verdict
because i thought it was fake
i thought it was a bit people sent me
that stuff and i was like
okay something's weird about that so we
should approach this in two sides one
talk about the fake side and the
outrageous result and then just talk
about also the story like this because
i'm sure it's a real story yeah it is so
we'll take it like both okay okay so
let's take first the second half where
we're taking it as if it's real bring
them out to the car no no no he's not
gonna eat that at all if you can't bring
enough for everybody lisa so you're
telling me that i gotta break so when i
buy my bring myself food i gotta bring
your kids food to them yes you sound
[ __ ] dumb how is that dumb you sound
dumb you sound dumb
you know that
no ladies
that's that christina aguilera
who sat down
i'm a genie in the bottom
okay but if you're going to bring one
you need to bring it for all
how do they look that i'm playing one
child eat mcdonald's and all the rest of
kids
she changed her story
she said she gets food stamps on the 7th
and now she getting them on the 11th
you know i don't get my food stamps to
the second you know i get food stamps on
that
[Music]
oh i pay attention to how a [ __ ] get
her money
[Laughter]
saturday that sounds like a [ __ ]
that i've been bamboozled before huh
when you get paid okay i'll see you
saturday
i get paid on monday
i don't remember bitch's name but i
remember should get paid
[Music]
hey what you would call it i give my
money down
[Music]
that's a bad habit of mine i don't
forget [ __ ] about money but anyways
let's keep going
three kids
three kids
yeah
okay but you still had a baby with me
who have kids with other people
[Music]
this one was definitely bugging like
what do you like if you listen to the
story
if you were to summarize the whole thing
it's like you didn't handle your
business and so you expect him to handle
all this all of your business he's
handling his he's taking care of his
child he's feeding it but it's a bit
like it's a bit like the guy the girl
that wants to go date
and the guy's paying
and she's expects him to buy food for
the kids yes the leftovers the left not
the leftovers
yeah cause you're paying for this date
so you're gonna pay for them kids and
i'm like
[Music]
responsibility
what's that i'm like oh
it's one thing to ask
can you grab the food from our kids nah
okay
how do you those are your kids
tell us on a date this is not your
boyfriend yet it's not your your husband
yet you want him to take care of your
kids but not like listen i ain't got
nothing against dating a single mom
that's it but handle your goddamn
business but no it's not i'm not so
somebody said this the other day he's
like yo he should be paying for the
for the babysitter if you want to take
me out on a date what
those are your choices in life i'm not
saying here to admonish you
that's cool
but don't expect me to come into this
thing where we're not even committed and
then start taking care of your
responsibilities
what are you talking about
the qual pow
at the end of the day is like this
you can't go out into this world just
dating casually expecting everybody to
pick up the work that you didn't do
that's your job
i got my job and i did my job now you
asking me to work overtime for zero
dollars
not only that you're not even asking me
you feel entitled and if i don't do it
which is already a ridiculous request
you got some choice words for me oh you
deadbeat you ain't [ __ ] this and that
and it's not even that is that who ate
[ __ ] if me yeah the person who's not
feeding your kids or you the [ __ ] who
didn't feed her own kids or if i don't
comply if i do not comply if i do not
comply to that
what's gonna happen
i might not even get a second date
i gave all this to eventually get a no
it's wild didn't that's why that yeah
but i did my makeup i did my you do your
makeup every day stop stop stop stop
right there stop and don't act like i
don't have to dress up i don't have to
look good i don't have to smell good i
don't have to prep myself stop stop
we're not doing this we have to prep too
at the end of all this i've done paid
for the food that's if you're you know
old-fashioned everything and stuff i
didn't pay for the food i didn't pay for
the
date and everything and stuff gave you a
ride to the spot
now i gotta pay for your babysitter pay
for leftovers and i might get a no hey
man it's 20 22. you seen gas [ __ ] you
gotta pay for that too
because i didn't walk here fled
friendship hey
i'm just saying okay it wasn't a
yabba-dabba-doo situation and i had to
put the gas in and so [ __ ] you
gonna pay video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn a vpn is an application or
an extension that you put on top of your
browser in order to change or to mask
your ip address you know to change the
location of your computer why would you
want to do that well sometimes i want to
listen to other content from other
country and they won't let me in knock
knock who's there canada won't let you
in unless you're from the uk
switch the vpn changer and then boom
knock knock who's there
it's actually the uk now
yes come in lord come have some feet i
know you guys don't speak like that but
you know what i mean so you're able to
watch much more content and then boom
the world is open to you just like
aladdin on a carpet i can show you the
world and for the next month you have 83
percent off and the three next month's
three if you use abba and preach code a
search vpn use the link below go ahead
and at this point with this lady like
with her son
with a child and everything and stuff
i'm just like
again we're just thinking about if if it
was real right
and at this point i'm like
stay lonely
stay alone if you asking for this on the
first date what you want to ask for the
10th stay alone don't stay alone it's
okay scared out of i don't have to argue
explain to you why you're wrong and
saying to you why you don't make sense
especially you all no stay alone deuces
we don't need to i mean there's a reason
why you got three baby daddies
it ain't no accident one okay two whoa
three
[ __ ] that's a pattern you only come
here with one [ __ ] piece of food for
one child the child that's mine silly
no that's dumb that you can't feed the
other kids don't feed nobody at all then
he can't take that
he can't eat it maybe if you had one or
two i can like you know maybe you got
these four is three extra keys what the
[ __ ] you all like going to my account
spend money on all those kids they're
something they're not my kids it's not
three it's three extra keys
so
let me be devil's advocate okay i could
understand a situation in which you know
you have half siblings you go out with
your dad your dad buying you gucci
outfits new playstation 3 food that you
can only eat you come back to the crib
where everyone's having dinner
everyone's eating food scraps and you've
got all this stuff i could understand
being the parent okay that like that's a
weird situation because they become
disgruntled you can't afford to pay i
could understand that that's something
y'all have a conversation about you
communicate you tell them make sure you
eat winnie with you so we don't have
this issue make sure he's not flaunting
this all over the house right i could
understand that i could understand that
yeah y'all could be like hey you know
what you wear you wear your daddy's
stuff actually that he has i can
understand that yeah i can understand
that but if he mocking and i'm spoiling
him
he's my kid and i'm spoiling him i'm not
gonna give him i'm not gonna not give my
kid good wait wait wait wait wait wait
because you two broke two so
which one is it you don't want a baby
dad that don't pay for child support
oh you don't want a baby dad that just
space [ __ ] full of skin which is it
what do you want
what do you want let's go
make me think of that lip what do you
want it's not that simple what do you
want that's crying that makes me think
of that them are your kids siblings
though
so that's that's that's what you're
gonna go with that's the one those are
your [ __ ] kids siblings
so don't no i just say you have to take
care of them you can bring them
something to eat if you bring one
something to eat
the logic is this
that's their half siblings
you a half daddy
[Laughter]
pretty
good that's her logic you are half daddy
now half daddy
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah five from you know one day i'll be
back
no you know what fine give it here thank
you leave it here leave me here
give me here
doug
he ain't eating it
you stupid stupid
selfish is like you're dumb as hell
you're dumb as hell he's not going to
eat that
take care of him anyway
he's not gonna do this you can't do it
for all don't do it for none of them but
i thought i was trying to take that
today
yeah i had another thing for him today
no he can't take it today
right now
there's so like me watching this i'm
like yeah you guys kind of heard my
thoughts on the mom so that's when you
need to talk about the whole altercation
and that kind of entitlement
i mean i can't i ain't got nothing
special to say that it's not obvious
you're bugging
you're bugging
me you're you're dead there's like
nothing else i can construct and tell
you other than
[ __ ] you bugging now that being said
fake or not
because for it to be fake that's a
long-ass altercation i'll give you two
one i thought the acting was very good
if it was fake it was fake
so that was really impressive normally
there's like little unnatural lines they
seem to like really flow well either
they rehearse it look like a
conversation
two i've heard people say goofy [ __ ]
like this before
so if it was it wouldn't surprise me
either there's a couple things i made it
look if i had to give a verdict whether
i thought it was real or not i must say
i'm gonna say real
what you gonna say i don't know
i don't know but there's some [ __ ] that
is fishy about that [ __ ] yeah
okay maybe i'm biased because i'm like i
don't i'm not the type of [ __ ]
that
that film everything there are some
people that film everything the food
they eat they take pictures of
everything they film every [ __ ] thing
right they film everything
and i don't comprehend that how i would
want to put my life out there
as
someone in the media as a public figure
i know that's something that can help
my
social media and stuff like that and my
money but i have like a
i have a blockage where i can't
post a lot of my [ __ ] like where i go on
vacation when if you see me you saw me
oh [ __ ] it's you yeah what's up i was in
atlanta the other day a couple of
[ __ ] recognized me thought i
don't post it like that
right i
i'm gonna make one post whatever to make
a point but i'm not gonna post
everything out of it i was out with some
[ __ ] saw me i'm not gonna you
know posting your your everyday life i
don't know so that's weird to me so
because that's weird to me i think
sometimes that i'm like hey you know
what people shouldn't act like that and
it's normal that people but people do
act like that so maybe it is real yeah
so i'm just gonna operate on the idea
that it is and i'm gonna just say this
easy solution
try not to have multiple baby mamas baby
daddies
just a thought listen i give two five
once you get past two on my [ __ ] stop
having kids
you need to chill
that's crazy
you got [ __ ] four kids each of them
with a dip my ass that's wild but i
digress that's the real big issue i
think in the whole thing here uh and
then the dysfunction that follows after
any other thoughts
no
[ __ ] was lying though she said she got
paid on the seventh and then she said
the 11th
i'm pretty sure are there
am i crazy just roll it back that's
that's a lie that's a lie she would lie
when she said that
let me see if i heard you know i don't
give my full steps to the second you
know i get food stamps on that
see
that little things like that that i'd be
listening
because i never get one of these maybe
it was just maybe she's just lighting
maybe she's just lying she's lying maybe
she forget the date maybe she mixed it
up real quick who knows i'm just saying
i hear things
what i hear
i hear things
i used to have friends i like that you
know i used to have friends you probably
you probably hear that you probably
remember that remember this
what because like their ears were
blocked